and curry the rebound curry averaged a
career-high
five and a half rebounds per game this
year gets inside draws the foul count it
and one
the finishing aspect that's just
beautiful touch around the rim
this year he became the oldest scoring
champion in the nba in 23 years
the ncaa got really mad at kentucky
they put cleveland state on probation
curry for three his first three-pointer
of the half
and from way downtown and it makes it a
10-point game again now
at the five position
[Applause]
and lebron james despite the horrific
shooting by the lakers especially their
stars
again they're only down eight curry
another three
back-to-back threes for steph curry now
he's got 12.
either are they curry step back three
bang
at the buzzer step curry from downtown
and the warriors will take a 13 point
lead
into halftime the spurs they'll play the
loser of this game
steph curry his third three-pointer he's
got 15
but this one was all about defense for
the warriors
as they hold the lakers to 42 first half
points
at best he's that third option and at
times carries them offensively
curry to green green trying to jam it
but james and drummond right there james
down the other end layup curry to green
green
trying to jam it but james and drummond
right there james
down the other end layup blocked a foul
count it and one still went down
and a chance for a three-point play
allowing the lakers to get to the
free-throw line
turning the basketball over and giving
them easy opportunities in transition
matthews and putting anthony davis at
the center position
matthews first minutes tonight curry
long distance hits a three
steph curry his fourth three-pointer of
the game you see
greatness and drake and michael b jordan
just shaking the head
as chef curry with the shot curry on the
drive
[Applause]
curry for three it's good steph curry
from way downtown
his fifth three-pointer of the night
three-pointers he's got 26.
we head to the fourth quarter here in
l.a
he's got to be great when curry rests
james drives on toscano anderson lara
banks at home
timeout golden state lebron james with
16 points
nine assists eight rebounds big buckets
lakers have turned it around in the
second half
and i think it starts with who you're
playing so wes matthews
he has been intense as james goes in
with the reverse
the laker lead is seven
[Applause]
curry for three answers steph
curry with his sixth three-pointer he's
got 29. not just on the shot but also
davis's rebound and finish
anthony davis discarded people curry
reverse
with the english off the glass with 3 15
remaining curry fakes curry dries
floats it up banks at home timeout
lakers
that's matchup but this is some ball
handling
hesitation and then the floater
[Music]
they get at the call while pope almost
lost it shot clock at seven
james two defenders on him to caldwell
pope inside he's tied up by green
throws it back up top james puts up the
three oh it's gone
it's a big time shot awful execution
realizes that the clock dwindling down
the good chase down by curry and
lebron elevates and knocks down the
biggest shot of the night that's a
30-footer and you see curry
who's had that look on opponent's faces
after he knocks down threes
the same look as lebron james with a
clutch shot